You don't
take the opportunity to deliberately
as an opportunity to have a conversation
with a very large number of people
because a good lecture,
it's our second conversation because
people in the audience going to make
sure that everyone's going in the same
direction,
but also to push my thinking beyond where
I've gone and telling you things that
are going to rely on
things that I think I know,
but I'm trying to lead them into something
new so I can push it just a little
bit far out we are.
That makes us a lecture because
there's something alive about that.
I'm curious to deliver by
delivering a talk to the content side.
I'm trying to learn some things that
are most important and I'm trying to do
that in real time.
So that's.
That's the plan.
So the first
rule is not what is expedient
because.
Because I think
there's a great question.
Our culture about whether or not the
experience of meeting or the real or the
experience say whether or not that's
real key is to figure out what's freedom.
You know,
we were founded.
The German back material
reality is at least clean that
we constructed the signed five years
ago and we believe that so far it seems
self evident to some degree is,
I mean there's something pretty
breathable material railroad
and our mastery of it from a technical
perspective in comparatively powerful and
increasingly so and so,
and it has improved our lives
as well and so you don't want to
denigrate the maturity was,
but
just because that's a good way
of looking at the world is be the
best way and it's also
actually not our people.
Look at the world.
It's just a company in the world and
the way that people
seem to in our world is,
is as if the experience of meeting is the
most real and I think you can see that
most particularly if people's responses
to pain because pain is a form of
leaving,
right?
Generative experience.
It's an emotional experience.
It's not self evidently material
because it has that suggested element,
but it's a very rare person.
That doesn't matter because if they
believe their pain is real and so I think
that's an interesting.
That's an interesting fact
because if you're nihilistic,
can you believe was like,
that's not meaning,
that isn't going to help
yourself with your pain,
and so even if you're an Ios,
we believe in the reality of
suffering about something,
you know in our ground students to realize
that actually here there's something
that I could take seriously even
in my dope and like disparate tape.
The fact that that
misery genuinely exists.
I can take that seriously and that's
actually a hell of a fine starting point.
Don't descarte the philosopher,
when he was looking for a place to stand,
he underwent the process
that you described as radical
without trying to doubt
everything you can possibly know and
they make any ended up only being able to
not go with one thing which was
that he existed as a person who go,
he couldn't doubt the existence
of social consciousness
and that's where the famous line I think
therefore I am looking from and you get
really be an ad for like proceed or or
my experience exists or something like
that.
That's something that I can get a
good job taking that are in part,
but I know go into that
so that you can't criticize
that fundamental axiom
with quite a bit of success
and I've even been
something that was similar,
although I didn't know it at the time
because I was looking for something that I
couldn't doubt that I couldn't do it.
I didn't really care what it was,
but if it's just like a for and for me,
it didn't end up being.
I think therefore I am.
It wasn't even the reality
of my consciousness,
which is where they ended up
with the reality of the pain.
I thought,
well that's the one thing.
I cannot demand it,
but the,
the,
the suffering exists as real mining
and other people and that's pretty
pessimistic in some sense.
If you think,
well,
the fundamental reality of suffering,
but I also learned at
approximately the same time,
but that was pretty high
level religious claim.
The might
listen in Judaism because
history of the Jews in history,
in some sense of suffering,
it's clearly the in Christianity
because of course the central finger
Christianity.
As someone who's nailed to a cross
courtroom to data and and guys,
you know,
incredibly painful back,
so even if even if it's not explicitly
laid down the fundamental reality like
the suffering sort of
right there as the image.
So
that's,
that's a very pessimistic way of looking
at the world and that might be true,
but it might not be because
obviously the fact that there's a
pessimistic stack is pessimistic about the
fact that you admitted to that back.
That's not necessarily so pessimistic.
You know,
imagine that you're afraid of
something that's hard to imagine,
but then imagine that you
can notice you're afraid.
Anything come to terms with it.
What that means immediately
is that no matter how large,
the furious that there's something
in you could recognize that and then
conceivably transcendent.
And one of the things that I learned
about understanding the reality of both
tragedy and malevolence because I
think those two things together make up
suffering and tragedy.
Use the fact that you're prone
to illness and an old aging,
you know,
all of those old buildings.
Look,
the flesh,
let's say,
and millennials of course,
is that there's always someone around
making who's willing to make it a more
worse than it has to be and that might
even be you fundamental reality of human
existence so,
but simultaneously there's that capacity
to serve that and contend with it and
then start to and then start to
work in forward looking manner.
Despite that,
and so one of the things,
the second thing are you going to say
after I was willing to put forward that as
a fundamental proposition,
the whole reality of suffering
is that way secondary.
That's,
that's not our most fundamental truth
for most fundamental truth is that people
are capable of transcending that and
so that takes the thing that's most
pessimistic and turns into perversely,
strangely and paradoxically immediately
turns it into something that's almost
unbelievably optimistic because you
can't imagine how you could possibly give
people more credit and the book
the most terrible thing you could.
Magic happens to be true.
Life is limited and rural,
tormented by this fundamental truth,
but if we admitted to that
at faith based or greatly,
then we can transcend it.
And you know,
you might think,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
Well,
the evidence for that,
it's actually overwhelming.
The first thing is while you're here,
you know,
I mean,
despite the fact that the fundamental
conditions of your life in some sense,
the group,
you get yourself out of bed in the
morning and you go do your difficult jobs,
that you take care of your families
and you exist in the world despite its
limitations.
And even more importantly,
and this is something I'll return to,
this is also something very much
we're thinking is that you know,
you've got a relationship with people
around you and some of them you actually.
And that's a strange thing because
those people that you love,
their lights are characterized
by limitation and there's
a lot and maybe three
to change it by a certain muscles in the
left ones and your judgment because you
do care for them,
is that despite all that they're around.
Because that's actually the judgment
that you make when you actually care for
someone.
Right?
You think,
well,
you know exactly what,
but despite their limitations,
really you actually care for the large
part because of their limitations,
which is a strange thing because
then the radio superseded and limitations
and weaknesses are all part of that
package.
It's not like you don't think that
maybe they could use some improvement,
but still the overall.
Chuck's,
when you love someone,
you overall general thing is
that all things considered,
it's been consistent,
that they are serious,
that's jumping
and I'm just thinking about myself,
but he was a kid.
No
kid,
especially kids from.
Well,
when they're under three,
they're pretty damn and
are resilient in some ways,
but they're,
you know,
they knew what the hell to do
it and just take note there.
That can hurt and so you have to be a
wait to make sure that nothing terrible
happens to them.
They're not holding too much by other
children or their siblings or their
parents for that matter.
You know the baby that they don't hurt
themselves when they're trying to learn
how to operate the chapter.
They're characterized by this
terrible vulnerability and it's,
it's kind of brutal.
The Roman,
because they can be heard,
you really get sick correctly.
This,
I don't know if it was much worse.
That can happen to you,
I don't think except maybe
to be this sick child,
him or herself.
There is much work to happen in your life.
That shop was a great deal.
That's rough.
I mean there's lots of terrible
things that can happen to you.
Maybe that's not the worst,
but it's definitely out there day.
It's rough and then you think,
well,
wouldn't it be better if your chunks
didn't ever have anything wrong with it?
And then you think,
well,
what would you have to do in
order to make that the case?
So the all that vulnerability,
that's painful disappeared.
First of all,
they wouldn't be three years old
while you were capable of
taking care of yourself and your
abilities.
You know,
maybe you don't necessarily want to be
free if you want them to be like 20 feet
tall.
So stellar human intelligence
and replaceable parts.
It's like,
well that removes a lot more.
It's not much less like your son.
It's just replaced it with a macro
themes that
kind of dream.
I'm really serious about math because
we're moving very rapidly to a narrow
artificial intelligence and robotics and
God only knows what would that be part
of a dream that we'd have to replace our
vulnerable selves on something and that
would not be anymore whenever
and wherever we are with this fear and
with all the misery of the world bicycle
that you could make a case that
maybe that's not for the worst,
but I think and so what that
means is we have to accept,
we have as part of your case for
existence and you might think,
well,
is it worth it?
And I think in to respond to it with kids,
take that person's ultimate Hazel for sex.
You're pretty damn happy,
but they're around under
current form and so that's,
that's,
that's something that's worth
thinking about as far as.
So back to meeting.
So
I spent a little time thinking
about how the brain works.
The brain structure is
stranger than safety
and no more stranger.
Again,
partly because we don't understand the
relationship between consciousness,
emphasis material,
substrate.
They don't really understand that are
hitting the science of consciousness.
That's pretty hard for about 30 minutes
now since it became somewhat respectable
as a you're making studying,
I wouldn't say progress.
There's something wrong consciousness
that's an intractable Mr. existence what
its relationship to its material substrate
and so that was interesting and but
it's also interested that your
post analytics is bifurcating,
right?
You'd have two hemispheres
and the medical division,
he didn't realize that human
beings before we moved around,
so if you follow the logic
of evolutionary biology,
it reflects a duality that's
built into reality itself.
If you make the assumption that reality,
that's the selection in the course
of natural and what is selected is a
reflection of reality,
which is like the Darwinian
truism essentially.
You can't really deny any of that.
It appears that has two
components to it as the case.
It's an implicit case,
mostly 12 rows like that that can be
mapped out using the language of chaos and
order.
Again,
think about the most with the idea
that the world is chaos and order,
which I think is a nice way
of conceptualizing that.
Well,
one is actually more real than almost
any other ideas and so if you say,
well,
once you're approved for that,
that will say what the fruit,
the fact that that's how your brain
discretion and not just curating also Adam
was praying so it's deeper than
just human and your left hemisphere.
This is,
this is an oversimplification
because people are slightly.
People are differently.
Lab realized that this is true with
your left hemisphere to specialized or
operation in territory that you explore
and understand and it's sort of a
totalitarian and experienced some sense.
It's always trying to impose its current
blogs on the world without having to
change them and you don't want to change
your model all the time because just to
cognitively effortful but so you're
going to take short cuts to preserve it.
If you can't because you put a
lot of work into your damn mall.
Here's the first mistake,
but it does make you kind of repeat it.
I'm able to admit to,
or a procedural error that seems to be
a left hemisphere function is primarily
associated with articulate speech and and,
and,
and operation in the
known explored character.
Now you know,
if you think about the tribal landscape,
might think,
well,
what,
what was the,
how was the world constituted for
much of our evolutionary history.
You can kind of think of it this way,
is that there was a fire and would
center things because we'd been hanging
around campfires for something on the
order of two years and the campfire,
the dark and said big,
right?
Then all the terrible things that lived
at the darkness that we're more than
happy to eat you.
And so there was no.
There was the fire as the center and the
place that the fire shot on light on.
And then there was the dark perimeter
beyond that where the predators lit up and
you can go out into the dark perimeter.
You can bring something of value,
but it's very dangerous team.
So that was really the
landscape of human based.
Its whole base of you to
your family and your tribe.
And then there's the
periphery that's from that.
You can think about that as explored
territory and unexplored territory.
That's a good way of conceptualizing it.
And that's the that dad really is explored
territory and unexplored territory.
Your spirit functions in the filmmaking,
unexplored territory,
and your right hemisphere
functions into domain,
unexplored territory.
What that means is you don't like it
when your right hemisphere turns off
because unexplored territory
is a place where things are.
And maybe even a horror movie now,
just learn would have your right
hemisphere through just to see what that's
like.
You could,
you could experiment with it if you can
explore it and maybe you could fortify
yourself with somebody because that's
what people do when they will see
thrillers are strangers.
Why the hell would you
see like this stairs,
20 bucks it just strip it out,
right?
We'll do that.
They're doing what I mentioned at
the beginning of this talk was there.
They're toying with
their own vulnerability,
right?
And they're attempting to.
We're watching narratives of adventure
or is we're planning with our
vulnerability.
When you rollercoasters,
you know we do that whenever we push
yourself off the edge and flirt with
potassium were toying with her.
We're also pointing with the big.
We're toying with our ability to move
out into uncharted territory and to
prevail,
and here's a.
here's a thought.
You know,
you might want to stay in
explored characteristics.
That's where it's safe.
The problem with that is that
explored I unexplored territory.
Various is saying,
I can just run down a date
because then like the dragon will.
You would have a pdf
that's food as strategy,
but if you really want to compare
yourself to the world or the world,
you don't just stay
where you're comfortable.
You stay where you're
comfortable enough going to die,
but you put one foot out where you
don't understand and then you balance
yourself there and you stay there
as much as you possibly can,
and that's actually what meaning is.
And I think that I think we know enough
about brain function actually say that
the sense of meaning that
envelops you when you're,
when you're occupied
property of your life,
is a neurophysiological
signal that you have.
The fundamental constituent elements of
reality in proper balance and you think,
well,
why would that be the case?
I mean,
let's be hard to get it right.
We're not going to get old
mythological and religious about this.
Let's be Africa.
We're going to stay in
there for materialistic.
Don't make.
It's like you're an evolved creature.
You're evolved for the actual world.
The actual world is made up
of things you don't want to.
Things you don't know.
A lot of things you don't
know are pretty dangerous.
Now you can stay where
everything is comfortable.
You can stay inside the walls,
but that's not very good strategy because
the things that are outside of the
wall can pick them up inside walls.
That's the state.
Regardless.
That's that's why in
paradise there's a state,
if they fall on paradise city,
which is are full of garden just speaks
to what the health of the state and then
there's no making a walled garden snake.
And so what that means is that not only
you have to be able to live with the
garden,
you bloody well better be
able to deal with the snakes.
And what that means is that's what you
should practice and would that mean that
you know that and when you feel
that things are aligned with your,
when you're doing things that
are meaningful and engaging,
what that means is that you've got
the balance between chaos and order,
right?
And that means that you're secure at
the same time you're extending your
confidence.
And then you might say,
what is that real answer is,
well,
how about survival is that's real.
How about the expansion of
the human capacity to survive?
Is there anything more real than that?
Well,
not from a Darwinian perspective.
There is.
And it could easily be that there isn't
anything more real then what's rebuild
from a therapy perspective.
And so I would say that the
sense of being an arrogant guy,
and it's interesting too,
I mean there's no shortage of religious
speculation on the depth of meaning.
I'll look at a particular symbol for
this for the sake of illustration.
So you know,
for whatever reason,
very mysterious reason,
the image of the crucifixion
has transfixed the van,
the imagination of
humankind for 2000 years.
Now it's not obvious why,
in fact,
it's quite obvious why it's a and to
put a symbol like that which is simple,
most painful death would be
trading something like that.
To put that in angels,
that took like 300 years to build
something with your ability to close,
they knew those things were
going to take 300 years to build.
It was like no moon shop,
you know,
was no joke.
Those things took a lot of work and a
lot of resources and they're all built to
encapsulate this symbol
is horrific symbol.
It's like,
what the hell's going on there?
What if you could,
if you look at it from a
detached a bit and think,
well,
there's mystery and there's an idea.
There's a deep fear that the idea is
that the fundamental adaptive pattern is
that which is is that which is
expressed in the radical acceptance of
vulnerability and the level of the
crucifixion represents absolutely.
The Passion story represents and the
reason it's a typical story independent of
its religious significance,
don't have not speaking.
Then physically speaking as a psychologist
is that there was an idea and the
idea is that if you strip
away everything from life,
you're living with the fact that your
vulnerability as an Oracle baiting and the
fact that you're subjugating,
okay,
the question is what do you do with that?
And the answer is the answer
that's expressed by that symbolism.
You accept him as radically and completely
as you can and the consequences that
can transcend that and all of our cultural
work that surrounds that symbol has
to bring that idea
up into something resembling
articulated consciousness.
You know,
and we spent all those thousands of years
similar being possessed by that symbol
in an attempt to try to actually
understand what it means
and that's what it means.
It means that your best is to accept
you crucified preconditions of existence
and to move forward.
Appeal towards the best thing
that you could envision.
Regardless.
I think that that is.
I do believe that an APP has never been
expressed in another Christian music
because it's such a well
known representation.
It's still something that's part of
our culture that everyone has to here.
But you see those sorts
of ideas expressed in,
in great stories from
traditional models of the world,
and it's the story.
It's the story of a radical
hero's language say,
and routing and encouraged,
and that's the courage to
dare to live in the property world,
which you
know,
sometimes you see people who are dying
and they look like good people because
they're not doing anything wrong.
You don't even have a conception
that things might be awesome.
They're like,
when you have good number,
those two issues in some senses,
to be the unconscious,
you know,
you're not a good person,
maybe until you actually
practice in Arabic so that
you've got some tea and then
decided that despite that your.
Despite that and despite the different
brutality in the world and you're going
to act as an agent in the world who is
devoted at every level that's possible
towards making things better of it.
Worse
asking
question,
are you ready?
First of all,
oh,
well,
what do you mean by that?
Exactly that what you mean by that.
It's the same thing
that I meant like that.
And then the next.
I think is what sort of trap or
exactly when you will laugh about them,
right?
Because that's interesting because the
trap in that statement is it's there.
It's not obvious exactly what it is.
You started with something like,
well,
here's formulate questions,
here's a set of potential formulate
answers and it's under one of those or be
like answers.
Here's a boss.
I can ignore you and walk away,
and so I was thinking now
I'm just thinking about that.
There's always the possibility
that I'm not answering it because I
take
it seriously because I
know
possible.
That's
important to answer that question
for a long period of time.
If you want to know the answer to that.
If you want to know that I have a lecture
series 40 hours long and you listen to
that because that large constantly
requires 52 hours if you record it.
Do you want an answer?
That question?
Here's a 52 hour
to have a serious answer.
I was thinking about that.
I think I just don't mind it a little
bit in this discussion that we've already
had it so hard to get small.
Okay,
so let's say it's a question of
what you might put your faith and let's
say you put your faith in something
because you don't know everything and
so he starting point and I think that's
actually true because you're fundamentally
eight different because you don't
know everything.
Then you have to ask as if some things
are fundamentally true or you just can't
be many.
Right?
That's true.
So then the question might be that some
things are fundamentally true in order
to exist at a in the world looking to see
what are the things that you should
act as the Afar fundamentally true.
And I can say,
well
I take the attitude that I've laid out
with regards to my three year old son is
a good example of that.
Again,
you might start by hypothesizing that the
fact that people exist as a good thing
rather than a bad thing and you know,
you might think,
well that's all instance
about a month and ago within
philosopher from South Africa
and he wrote a book,
the kind of person I can't
remember unfortunately,
but his basic presupposition
and he lays this out,
but it hasn't been very
large number of followers,
absolutely catastrophic,
horrific and miserable
and it would be better if
you think that's pretty useful,
but he actually thinks that we're all
able to bring someone into the world,
not to.
You know,
you haven't taken any sort of argument
with a certain degree of seriousness
because I know that when women are
thinking about having children and not,
the reason they decided not to express
is that they don't want to bring a child
into a world like this and it's
usually because they have some mouse.
This apprehension,
but now it's worse than
any other time in history.
Which is so absolutely not true that
this is just a miracle that you can think
serious.
The census.
You bring somebody into the world
that they're going to suffer and die.
Perhaps something like retreats
being itself apart,
so much suffering.
It's actually not
fair.
Now.
It was two things.
One is that if you accept
that you don't stop there,
you can't just say,
well,
I think being is unjustifiable and
so we shouldn't have any more bs.
Argument doesn't stop there.
The argument,
it's to be unjust celebrating and that
makes me bitter and angry and vengeful
and destructive and then I
take my revenge on the world,
and so when you look at the motivation
of people who these terrible things in
the world,
they start with a presupposition.
That being is is intrinsically feedback
and then proper role is to do something
to take advantage of that and that's
like a bad argument because it's being as
expensive to be bad,
maybe get a hell of a lot worse because
of what you're doing is not a solution.
So I think that
I would also say the problem with that
lack of argumentation is that it actually
does underestimate seriously underestimate
him with regards to the counseling,
the grandeur Europe,
the human spirit.
Because I do think that white is treasure,
can you just buy my level?
If you look at the facts of the matter
rush that human beings are so remarkable
that they can actually continue
with that and make it work.
And so I would say as I said,
get the hell out of bed
in the morning despite,
you know,
there's lots of people in this audience
who are carrying some pretty vicious
burgers maybe in one or
two per 10 different ways,
you know,
because lots of people and you will be.
So
if you're not open profitability that you
have a first degree relative can start
something fairly serious wrong with it.
It's pretty damn high.
And if you happen to be one of those
periods in life where that is happening,
make more power to you because
you don't make assumptions.
But,
and still,
despite that fact you're getting,
how often do you go to work?
And most of you are miserable.
We're trying to make everything
worse as a consequence.
So like we need to be.
Because
if you go into a shop or a liberal diners,
say you go there and get a cup
of coffee and fresh orange juice,
get some that are part of one
side versus the left writing,
so it means that they've managed to
transcend that tracks for your very
existence
when they go unnoticed
and I don't make sure
you understand what
people truly bear.
If you opened your eyes to that and you
see them through a simple glance of all
the you accept that suffering,
something like that.
Then the fact that someone just pleasant
to you when you go to the diner in the
morning and ask for a cup of coffee in
his mirror and I really think that isn't
the case.
I also think that that's an antidote to
the sorts of toxic ideas in our society,
like the fact that the
planet will be better off.
There weren't so many people.
I think it's the last
thing that you would want.
Anyone who's hand was near
the nuclear button to,
for example,
or somehow was cancer on the face of the
planet and that our very existence is
indication of our toxicity because of
all you can have a little sympathy for
ourselves.
You know,
we're the only creatures on earth.
The struggle forward under incredible
psychological distress APP.
It's built right into the
fabric of our and given that
we did pretty damn well.
People don't,
and we're doing,
we're doing everything we can say as far
creatures to make things better rather
than worse.
And you can tell about,
because I came here today,
this is a pretty nice place to trees
no
to like trees
and you don't care.
And most of our cities,
especially in North America,
Europe,
here's
structure,
no water,
so
you have a.
You can go off the street.
No one kills even takes you all.
I'm always happy.
That is the baseline condition.
Keep an
no easily societies to
generate the absolute mayhem
and how often that happens.
It's
still know to remind
me
there's not going to get it to as well.
So you know,
we'll use,
right?
Because if it's cash for coffee,
how fragile systems are in general
in every moment where that has been
happening,
it's actually a kind of miraculous human
spirit and one of the things I would
say is we have a pretty decent website,
like our society is pretty damn civilized.
I know their flaws and resources
that are given are distributed,
will be,
and that's obviously caused
a certain amount of trouble,
but it can be a hell of a
lot worse than the extent.
We're pretty damn fortunate
that things are good.
You can take a certain amount of credit
for that because the reason they're good
is most of you are pretty
trustworthy and so how have
you seen around the world and in history,
there's so many corrupt states and once
the society is at the state and that
will not be individually level.
The baseline interaction between people
is predicated on trust on virtually
impossible to figure
out how it gets going.
You can't trust anyone around you
and how do you start trusting people?
It just never seen.
It's just something that doesn't
seem to ever get off the ground fall
interaction in the west and increasingly
I would say the rest of the world that
the world is actually one of the trust.
I can give you an example of this.
This is a small,
um,
I think I've told this story was
in a chapter I cut out at 12 olds,
but it will be in the next
20 years ago.
And he drove in the car.
It's a little cadillac and a
rainstorm and hit the brakes and the
car into a wall right on the corner.
It's about,
because it takes the bumper panel and
the closing thing,
he was all embarrassed.
I decided to get the
car fixed or something,
if it's like worth more
than what we can do that.
And so I went online because,
you know,
people want to fix your car.
You can go online if
you could describe it.
A partner in geography result for
a good deal.
So I waited,
did this guy from Mississippi,
he said,
I kept that part and so we communicate
by email and he said he wanted some
ridiculous price for $160 for the whole
assembly and it's going to ship it,
recharges,
brings to that deal and I wouldn't be so,
so that was fine and I
just went over to the yard and I found
out that there's a plastic piece on the
side and it has the
scratching and I thought,
that's so amazing.
It's like you're a
geography the Mississippi,
I'm never going to get you don't know
who they are and you already gave me a
pretty good deal on this part yet.
You caught me scratch.
Well thank you.
That's great.
Very good.
And then it extended scratch.
Really?
Scraps likes to be on the oven.
He called me again about 15 minutes later.
Wait a sec if you want.
Did you want the bumper?
The Lights?
And I said,
well I specified that in,
you know,
my original request.
I want to propose assembly 70.
It was just for the,
you know,
the barrier,
their shell because we
already made the deal,
honor and I thought,
damn,
civilization works.
Excellent resources.
There's a great book I read called the
poverty of nations normally version
anyways,
it doesn't matter.
It was written by a Harvard professor.
He was trying to figure out why some
cultures and other cultures are for and he
did an interesting analysis.
He compared the western hemisphere
countries that were settled by Portugal,
Spain,
France to Western countries and what he
basically thought was that because of
English common law
structure and the tradition.
So if you were settled by England,
brew rich,
the other countries,
then you can do.
And again trying to down and understand
why is basically which was countries
with common law tradition produce this
produce individual interactions that are
fundamentally predicated on trust.
And that's what made rich.
And you also have in Japan and
Japan is very interesting society.
But maybe I've known right.
All they have is like rocks and rights.
The rights that I think if we don't agree
on price because it's too expensive to
grow there.
So.
But they do have interpersonal trust.
You're stable enough and
so rich because of that,
and so his people is.
You're fortunate you're camping.
Maybe it might come to me.
Was that the only genuine naturally
resource was honesty of trucks and
I think there's something broke up.
It's deeply true,
so okay,
so back to the idea of meeting.
It's like,
well,
if you experience meaning in your life,
when you move your comfort into the
unknown and you do that because you're
courageous enough to take on the burden
of your own vulnerability and to expand
your competence and when you do that
properly engaged with the world and you
feel that your existence is worthwhile
and you feel bad because you are in fact
making yourself better in a way.
It's also making things better at
the same time and then rely on.
That's reliable.
Mark.
I said,
well,
what should you have faith in?
Let's say in terms of
your fundamental axiom?
You could start by causeways
existence is to do it.
You could start by,
you could say,
I'm going to access this acetates.
Obviously you can just
do that in a serious way.
If you will one way in one seven,
which is I think if the world gets
better when you make the other decision,
consequences of purchase,
which is the world gets worse,
so you would say,
well,
as this being itself is justifiable,
and then let's take the further step in.
Our proper role is to accept
the world
and then so people see that
that's the right way.
It's like blocking.
I think that it's
justifiable proper role.
It did not be of use to do everything
we possibly can to make things as good
and then that sound that's a.
that's active.
Our statement about a set of propositions.
Do you.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by believe it or are
you talking to the set of articulating
double socks,
so like that's not the deepest form of
policing to be in the form of bleeding.
What's
the alternative is to make
everything worse and maybe
it's a bad idea.
It also can I get also
in some sense to me,
because I do believe that the human spirit
is in some senses and going on almost
like we could.
Maybe of what we all
trying to make the ask,
at the very least,
I know that it stops things from
degenerating into the kind of absolutely
catastrophic health and we experienced
in the 20th century and that will to
avoid
paradise on earth.
If we can all work towards
the kingdom on the hill,
we could make sure that we get these
backwards into the sorts of counsel
characterized
in the Soviet Union,
be well.
We're going to accept the
team is justifiable parking
by noticing that despite
some we've already made that judgment
way and we're going to act as if our
proper role in life is to
take the overwhelming weight
of our on our shoulders
and work to make things better regardless,
which is a really noble pursuit,
right?
You know,
because you might think,
well,
how is it possible given your current
circumstances and wretchedness that you
could possibly have regard for yourself,
for yourself?
Self esteem,
because I hate that phrase,
but for yourself and say,
well look,
if you know that your.
Your fundamental conditions of
existence are tragic with the touch of
malevolence just to make it worse
and if your eyes are open to that,
do you understand the catastrophic
nature of that and then just wipe that.
You just started.
Your job is to wake up in the morning
and put things right and maybe you could
also say,
well,
you know,
such a bad preacher,
all things considered that I could take
down and still work would be to help
myself with everyone else on board
to help with otherwise the birch.
So here's
check in with no ability
to justify your business's
existence in the world.
That's what we need
is disappears because
baseball is good for you.
Enjoy it and I'm running
through the storm because of students
and if happiness is what's keeping you up
and you sing and that's good because the
storms are always coming and so what?
You need something that will
get you through the store
and the idea that there's
something to struggle this.
It's like,
yes,
that's something you can take to the
bank and if you have that road in the
world,
not only will you make your own life
better and you make yourself stronger and
improve your character and make
things better for your family,
for your society,
and so that sense of meaning.
This is something that also is true,
is that sense of meaning that orients
in relationship to the node and also
orients you towards the
the what would you call it,
the stacking of different levels of being.
So in order to properly in the world,
you can't just exist for yourself because
you don't just exist right now that
you exist right now and you exist.
You exist.
It's month next year,
so you have to act in the moment such
that the probability that you will
continue to exist and happen at those
other traits and also civil exists.
So that means that you have to bite your.
You're actually the present
or the necessity for your
continued to propagate you
to cross the discovery in future.
Something that's very unique to humans.
So you have to take into account your
future self and that's very much different
and taking it to other people
and you also have to do that.
If you're going to exist in the future,
you're going to exist in a way that
makes other people want to exist because
otherwise things might
fall apart pretty down you.
You're done,
you're gone and so misbehaving in any
fundamental way isn't that long term
survival,
so you might think,
well to act properly in regards to
your future selves at something like
integrated with the gratification and
sacrifice and you haven't been out in a
way that also benefits your family
and that also benefits your community.
And I'm also saying
that's the last to close
and the client that there's no
such thing as a fundamental.
It's something like this.
The world is so complicated that you can
interpret and that actually happens to
be true.
The world is so complicated in this
and you can see it definitely like our
vision is a real mystery,
but the fact that there's an infinite
number of ways of potentially interpreting
the world is not for a moment.
If there's an indefinite number of valid
ways of existing in the world and when
you think about the constraints
that are put on your existence,
then you can see the proper ways of
existing in the world start to shrink to a
very,
very school range.
I said I really like to bit about this
idea since some of you might have heard
some of the things that's upsetting or pha
purposes,
analysis of children's gates,
children's Microcosm Society,
which is what children white about
African societies would be generate toys,
societies,
which is video games or go
see the movie by the way,
you generate twice society.
Then you practice
affidavit signed the past.
It's,
it's.
It has the same structure as real society
except that lower resolution children
or giving them a loan with playing because
they're actually practicing learning
council exists.
It isn't trivial.
That's a good indication that they're
following the path of meeting in the world
and so it would be a good thing.
For example,
if our children are school
children more than they planning,
so,
so children,
so piaget was very interested in
what made me gain and some rules,
good game.
You can play iteratively and that's a
good thing to know that you're going to
play the same everyday.
Well that's
something to think about too is you know,
because a lot of people make the mistake
of thinking the exceptional things they
do in their life,
like the vacations they take and so forth
are the important things in there and
that's just absolutely not true.
The thing is every day are they important
the gay thing.
But I had a client who was spending
about 45 minutes to sort of
don't
make your children do anything to make
him decide he was spending about 45
minutes and I'm fighting with
the sun to try to get into back.
And so I knew the parents actually only
spend on average about 20 minutes a day
with your kids.
Like a direct one on one contact,
direct contact law
enforcement at the time.
And so you're spending 45 minutes and
right before was your kid was like,
that's twice as much time as you normally
spend with them and if you think that
that's good and well and
you're not thinking about.
So people don't like it when I do this
because people don't like to risk to
take,
but we get 45 minutes a day,
about five hours a week,
eight hours a month.
So that's half a work.
Maybe people quite that by 12 and that
six weeks a year or a month and a half.
So basically he was spending
at least a year with his son.
It's like that's a good game.
That's not against anyone's going to win.
It's interesting to do that risk
with regards to the things
that you repeat every day.
Exactly what your is made up of.
Those things that you repeat.
And so what we want to do is get
those mundane things that you repeat,
pristine white trope that
enroll of cleaning up your room.
It's like when you live in the damn thing,
it's quoted in order
to go to the next step.
And they can manage that.
And it's just my room.
It's like,
well that's one way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it,
it's,
it's a microcosm of being.
If you have that hand and if it's.
And it's like,
Whoa,
what the hell are you up to?
Speed.
Really?
Is it fine?
So if someone gets you
a country to roll on,
you,
pull up your socks,
get your act together,
what is shaped?
And everybody has to be able
to play it over and over.
But everybody has to play against the.
It's so cool.
Because he was,
he was asking,
he was actually trying to reconcile this
ancient between science and religion
that was Australian,
our intellectual life.
And he was trying to understand the
evolution of morality and one of his
observations,
what's not.
Children spontaneously play and their
games tend to awards playable games.
And I play a little game is one where
everyone is treated with a certain operas
founded as a player and everyone
actually wants to play the game.
So it's voluntary and that's a pretty
good definition of a free society.
It's like you get to play and you get to
planning both if it's set up and so and
so.
That's another indication of the fact
that there's something about a fundamental
ethic.
These are just arbitrary and this is
very important thing to get 21st century
because one of the things that we kept
blaming in the 20th century was the any
old arbitrary arbitrary.
It doesn't matter if they're Marxist
or capitalist on the arbitrary.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong.
That's a seriously long scientific
data or the philosophical data or in
very constrained we can orient ourselves
in the world and when they boil down to
I would say a seven fundamental blocks.
Have you been to a sovereign and I
mean everybody has intrinsic value of
societies.
It's not asking for axiom
in the old world,
not convinced.
Maybe perhaps you shouldn't be.
You might also avail yourself of the
relevant literature because some of the
most brilliant people who support.
I can counter trends to wall.
For example,
who's the primatologist who was probably
the world's foremost neuroscientist of
emotions,
both studied the emergence
of morality in racks.
That was Kinda your wall demonstrated
quite clearly with the chimps is
particularly interesting.
Brutal children don't want to tar is that
are predicated on power to kind of be
the chip patriarchy.
I'm serious.
I'm really serious about patents.
That's the view of the world.
Every hierarchy is brutal and it started
in my apartment and that's the most
important for talking back
because they're tragical.
You will demonstrate quite clearly of our
chimps are very unstable on the people
and the tubes are very likely to meet
an extraordinary model and so he showed
that for the organization was on
state and it's not surprising,
right,
because you could choose to be nice.
So when the big wheel thing,
little rebel essentially
as a consequences.
So you can see this emerge of epic
farmer below they don't know and yeah,
and this is something he should
have won the Nobel prize.
He was an absolute genius.
He was the first point in
place or a certain way.
That's a big deal.
They don't know.
Our capacity for play is
actually a consequence of a
separate biological system.
That's a major discovery
study.
Rats,
rough and tumble play in particular,
which is a very interesting field with
all others tend to do with your kids and
it seems to be one of the primary ways
that you would father socialites that
geography and so it's very
fun,
was the last were to earn the right to
engage in rough and tumble play and so
that's how you tell them and was motivated
to see if it would work for something
that's kind kinda the same way.
You figure out if you can be a little
bit and ratchet work under reading over
that you'll be able to
wrestle with another bad,
especially if they're young juveniles,
especially if they're juvenile males.
If you pair two together and one of them
was 10 percent bigger than the other,
the big brother stole the halo,
the little rap consistently and so
then you get to your experiment.
You just paired once
and big rats go say hi,
go ahead and start.
These are predicated on power.
That'll be your conclusion.
It's like,
yeah,
you missed something and what you missed
because you don't play with someone.
Once you blend with them over
and over and over and over,
and the rules that govern
gain continues across a large,
safe like your time are not
the same rules that govern it.
You will be played once
because if you're playing,
imagine you're not claiming a set of
games and then imagine that the rules for
winning a set of gates are not the same.
Rules are living one game and then
you don't care about winning one game.
If you have any sense because you're
not just going to play one game,
you're going to play games and so then
you want to know what the rules are that
govern victory across the set of gates.
And I would also say that the reason
that aren't religious presuppositions
evolve and this can
pick them up this year.
This idea,
the reason our preset positions evolve
as because we'd be trying to formulate a
picture of the proper action patterns
that enable you to attain victory across a
set of all possible games.
And that's a very,
very difficult thing to figure out.
But you kind of know what you tell your
kid when you say it doesn't matter what
matters and the kid system.
What do you mean by that?
You say,
I don't know
why kindness dual.
They don't all have no holds
barred and do whatever I have.
When is that supporting the beginning?
It's like no one's done.
If someone reporting to
the point of the game,
distribute the of the game is to play
the game in a manner that ensures that
your complaint,
that most masculine number of
gates that everyone at this age,
that's the point,
right?
And so part of that is
trying to lead each game,
but there's so that's one level,
but really trying to it,
but there's a level of reality
was that it's trying to again,
in a manner that ensures that everyone
wants to keep playing with you because
then you'll never get out of people to
play with your entire life and that's a
bit.
That's just what you're telling
your son or your daughter.
When you say it doesn't matter,
it matters how you play and you wouldn't
know that except for the fact that
people have struggled to
conception unconscious for
tens of thousands of years,
will attempt the problem with the fact
that we iterate our processes across time
and so we,
we,
we built pictures of what you attitude
in life has to be like if you're going to
be the person who has a good chance,
maybe the process,
who has a good chance of winning across
the broadest possible of circumstances?
I don't mind when you accept it,
you kind of from that,
if you pair it their backs together once
the big round of established dominance,
then it was up with the little rep to
invite like so the next time you put the
rat skimming the liberal come out,
you know,
go out.
So they want to play.
It kind of clipped the rear end,
the down the clumps around like
everyone knows this language,
you know,
and you can pretend you're a pretty.
Tends to fight.
He's a good guy.
He actually doesn't like this.
Your first accident.
Don't smack him,
even dogs down,
so in the middle of that mess.
So I'm going to get out,
you know,
does this play invitation
to debate your APP?
And then the big little smoking
kind of nondescript and
I stopped once ready,
but yeah,
I would feel complaints and so then
he was place and he doesn't let men 30
percent of the time,
little rumbles asking for anymore.
And I read that.
It just blew me away.
It's so I'm.
And they're thinking repeated
like voluntary playbox.
So that's where ethics comes from.
I see.
Well that's something,
that's something to discover it because
he came to think of ethics is something
like an arbitrary articulated
and then couldn't be,
couldn't be one thing.
It couldn't be Marxist,
couldn't be capitalists.
It couldn't be any number of arbitrary
set of rules like no one could quite
isn't arbitrary there even racks on.
So they what do you need or
even the humanity itself.
And so that's something that's
very much worth knowing.
So.
So let me
just one rule
books,
meaning
nationally was the case.
That's the landscape that you can have
and then your job is to expand it into
order
and the way you do that is by having one
of your challenges and then
you can tell what you're doing.
You're engaged in what you're doing.
That's the mark from the deepest levels
of your reading that you have the
constituent elements of reality property
and then imagine that that's balanced
in a way that doesn't just work for you
or you on your future cells and works
for you and your family and your
community perhaps thing beyond that,
and that's why his excuses you
with that sense of engagement.
That's
I think it coordinates with
the best evidence we have
functional and so wouldn't
that be someone?
Whatever being is like is intrinsically
be and you've been with guide.
Is that sense of being will also help
you transcend a tragic existence or how
are you encountering it
will help you set the world.
Right and furthermore,
we're giving you that sense of
being that comes with knowing that
your weight of your existence on your
shoulders
and stumbling towards
the change so to speak.
Just make sure that that's
the fundamental story.
Yes,
it's correct and I think it would be a
lovely thing if we all woke up the 21st
century and understood that consciously
and did everything we possibly
implementing pounds.
Yes.
That's
so true.
He
didn't.
This is actually.
Jordan's going to be the best word
tonight.
It could all come.
Right.
Awesome.
What you just heard in
the last hour and a half,
30 years ago when you started doing this,
people would be dressing up like upstairs.
It's a funny thing because,
well,
for example,
Courtney
surprised
stamp.
What level?
Not surprised.
I'm not surprised just because
when I learned that they just.
They just.
Why?
You know there's some things in that
nature is amy.
I think I practice the old stories,
one of the people to that story.
When I finally understood that those
stories that I never written off,
it was so absolutely overwhelming
because it's a story.
It's the Mesopotamian story,
Fish Egyptian story.
They just,
at the beginning of those
stories have that modal forced,
pushed the whole culture
for thousands of years.
If you kind of stumble across what the
story means and you'd see the power,
let's not surprised,
and I asked her
what's the base that I got to teach
when I was teaching this was just benign
neglect
rail.
So it's not surprising stories
because they are exactly
the kinds of stories
and so
carl is a genius and a
perfectly proportioned,
staggering my fingers back into and so
yes,
it's terrible to say
you're within a great story and we need.
We need to have a pre tools
generation after generation.
It's absolutely necessary and so
this is a manifestation of that.
I think we'll see.
We shall see.
Wouldn't be the order that is
probably most important one.
When will you be doing
a duet with Kanye West?
You've been talking
about music a little bit
harder.
You're good to go.
Alright,
here we go.
Shannon still
interestingly,
so the first thing,
the gym still reflects the light,
right?
And why does the system look at the
beach and then like it's associated with
consciousness and it's
associated with the idea.
That whole idea that the some hero
hero is the database that confronts the
private therapist at night and balanced
way through that and Victoria says
a morning and so that's part of the
condemnation with the idea of life and
to have something that reflects like
this,
to have something that partakes of that
heavenly process of civil thing and so,
but then there's another
level of analysis.
It's really interesting.
This is quite iron man for example,
in the avengers movies basically
as a crystal that keeps them a lot.
It's easy enough for Casa del chemical
transformation towards goal as part of
them.
That's logical substructure.
That story like a crystal
and crystal is very,
very interesting material object because
pure crystal diamond is exactly the
same at every level of analysis.
Like all of the molecules in Math Olympiad
are lined up perfectly.
Everything.
So it's one thing and that's like so part
and it's the fact that it's one thing
that makes it respect and so there's a
synchronistic relationship between the
purity and the hardness of the stone
and its ability to reflect and to the
nation and the implication of that for
a human made you want to do is confront
even pressure to transform yourself into
something that's one thing and every
possible level and then you also reflect
and that's also metaphorically speaking
and that's something that's symbolized by,
by,
by the job still and that that
gives you an example of how we are,
you know,
because like sparkly things
that those things are regardless and what.
It's just some arbitrary,
not arbitrary,
the jokes to all shake them and giving
them to people because it's a symbol of
permanence and don't
want to make like that.
So to speak.
Yeah.
The
Christmas tree
to bring the idea to
celebrate in darkness,
to celebrate the of the
light in the darkness,
to associate the idea of the night and
the darkness of winter would be birth of
the redeeming hero,
which is dark.
It improves it.
And so all of that stack up and ritual,
this body that you undertake,
it's so fascinating to see the test
case because we have wisdom that
understands,
which is to say that more and
more complicated as we know,
obviously the case,
even representative things that you don't.
We go see movies like Harry Potter,
for example,
can be
kids to read seven slash $600
stadiums and they would all
come with Mrs Virgil Stories,
a
whatever movie empire generate
telling these stories.
What was the story she told?
She joined us an orphan hero who
was willing to die for artists.
Heard that story before.
Great
recedes into the background state.
What's happening with
Christianity and new mythological
imagination.
That's exactly what Scott wants
to
screen,
and so luckily it has enough
power to rejuvenate itself and
engineering price per superheroes
marbles,
worst
actually collapsed,
collapsed.
I can reduce use of
nature.
Nature predicted
because of the fundamental
narrative you described,
that as you celebrate,
you will never find enough water to wash.
In Twentieth Century Relief
Pitcher,
he
described the sort of character which
you get from the Russian revolution.
So could you lose you lose your ear
angel differentiated into their tribal
communities,
completely out,
or we will lose faith in life and I'm not
listing for that gender and science at
the same sleep as well as
being depressed and anxious,
desert bitter and resentful and
cruel and murderous and genocidal.
Even
Mr.
conditional assistance or explicit
systems are metaphorical narrative that's
facing our industry
function and lose that.
It's whatever your last ideas
that I've been describing,
what your responsibilities is to
rescue him from the belly of a whale.
Watch you think about
90 percent of this audience it and don't
launch
into a whale.
That makes sense.
Why don't we use,
which is just absolutely beyond
that.
Make sense?
No
father's house
all the way it members all
the way to ancient Egypt.
The I'm not.
It's an idea.
You can see as as the,
as the,
as the corpus of your
produce.
People with more.
No,
it was good.
Despite the data and there's a spirit
that animates and it's necessary for you
because your historical
structure,
it's necessary to revitalize the spirit
of that three in order to live you
chaplin property without a preacher,
and so am regeneration,
ethical responsibility
of every generation.
To go into the underworld,
which is to face the things
that you're most afraid of,
which is the fire breathing dragon.
I'll tell them to somebody else.
Springs a fire breathing dragon.
Remember what happens
when we don't breathing,
drag it out of the with the and
drag and about
competitors in danger of permanent.
You're kind of assessing him.
Just let him speak yourself
and as a consequence,
he washed the beach.
What the temperature is a terrible,
horrific rep council will be
necessary part of the ethical
and so
that's another example of how these are
so you have tried yourself back into the
past to resurrect the spirit of your
traditions because of the lost and the
problem with the last first and the second
is to make you susceptible to second
grade religious structures,
even forms and the ideologies
because you're not going to like.
You're either going to be cost
or if you open up like fundamental
really fundamental soul,
deep market,
differently structured,
we're going to be in soccer for the first
person who comes along and halfway to
need and that's not getting
a university education
sometimes weird sometimes.
I know I've been a
little bit.
Thanks
for
changing my life.
They're not as much changes.
There has been a certain
breakfast as
well.
What I'm
getting
from
twitter,
especially
twitter requires at the
end of the day that's bad.
You should watch and wait until the
correct thing is to say that's what you
should have.
Great piece.
I think we should just quit.
One of the things I've
learned that it's perhaps
you know versus what you
should do when people attack,
you can try to make it
real number of kids.
You always use necessary
force to basically move
necessarily forced to defend yourself
because why would you say people are
forced to not
miss any situations?
You know,
because the situations where I kept my
head when things are uncomfortable in the
student demonstrations in some of those
that are comfortable and it was pretty
severely.
There were some people
in those demonstrations,
there was a small minority of the people
and we're definitely aiming at making
the world a hell of a lot worse.
It was the blow in and they're are of
people that you want to have an arts
reaching
the right responses to react with,
react in a minimal way and still putting
your ground and what's happened as a
consequence of implementing that as far
as I can tell is that every time you tap
in that map in public if consequences,
that has ended up being good for
me and so that's the interesting
part
because he was.
It wasn't that art
because
I don't know what you think you're
talking to and it's certainly not me.
Someone that was.
It was like watching somebody
jogging to.
Fortunately I didn't react
except minimally and that
really work and so it's a
good thing to learn.
If you can learn to do with.
It's hard because if you're being attacked
and if they completely.
You don't have to do that.
You just asked sufficiently
and so when you see npcs,
you experienced that packet pressure
in your life that you want to stand.
Your brother's been necessary for us as
the most effective possible strategies
for a second.
What about the other words that just
describe the people that get that look.
Just showing you the university
truly scared.
That's
awesome.
You try to get yourself
in a manner that's generated
with a number of people possible,
and so if we seriously gave me a
destruction of eventual destruction,
the best allison
rush toward the.
It's
hard.
It's hard to defeat
someone who knows nothing.
So
what advice do you have?
His father's passed away while being
traded to the company.
You could say the spirit is everywhere.
One of the things that I
was that
breach cigarettes,
the father,
us.
Everywhere in the libraries
you can choose your heroes
and mentors from the people,
whoever,
and so the prompts of
institute as mature anyway,
something like that.
You have a personal father.
That's another reason
why this notion of it
detached from reality feel that
transcended immediately.
So you might say,
well,
it's incumbent on you
to worship this part of,
what do you mean?
Psychological
assessment,
the spirit as a pattern.
The pattern is generating civilization
and you even conceptualize that.
It's pretty easy to conceptualize
that as a journalist being a spirit,
that's something
experience something like making
more than that and some more
on the rails and the way people used to.
I'm looking at
because that's another really interesting
thing about people and interesting
thing that you and yourself and you
notice how you react in the world in the
middle
or the actions of the people that Meyer
and it isn't like you're doing that
voluntarily.
It's like you just noticed
that that's in some sense.
That's the instinct to worship.
Worship is the instinct
we imitate which it is,
and if the instinct to empathy is work,
which it is,
then the fact that you can be gracious
is the way you bet your unconscious line
oreos with words,
good world crips outside
of an architect works.
It's like,
well,
not that I'm really fascinated.
Got a trap line out and I'll focus on
them and it is attempting to do something
that happens.
You can also use that as a guy.
Talks a lot about this when very profound
psychological transformation where you
spent talking to me
and he said the artist,
his transformation was his observation
of people who dr themselves.
Um,
what was impossible.
Nobility,
brutally difficult situations.
Now
I would say perhaps hundreds
of stories of people like that,
that encounter.
He was in the council and so he started
to notice that those people exist and
that there was something in him that
was responding with the gardener
admiration,
who's incorporation that will
completely transformed world.
And so that's,
that's the rediscovery of the fog.
That's part of the process of registering
the fondant group wave it seems.
That's exactly what this
question was asking.
This is what my understanding.
That's the question that's important.
It's like,
why don't you turn from the reverse
with father to the spiritual,
which is something you have to do with
your maturity when it's it goes or you
lose the spirit of is that if you don't
replace your personal father with a
trans person before and
your different mature,
your personal father who you
essentially get psychological,
you got and you see people
when they're like 40 years old,
the reason they haven't taken
the pattern of the spirit,
the father away from offered and putting
it into the transcendent space where
there's tremendous utility in doing it
and now say the in the metaphysics of the
spirit of that question,
so let's just go with the spirit
middle somewhere and perhaps
there's something that even more,
and this is
the psychological idea
of the transcendent.
The laundry is not something
that you want to snap,
like look,
don't give precedent that of course
the temptation is to become a chain
tensioner.
That was good because the person is the
king indicate uses the reasons about
is because God is thought precedent.
Precedent is
God is
sovereign already.
It's.
It's the board with the
idea of that's great.
Report is extracted away from any
carrier and made a princess or the trend
principle and then the president is
subordinate to that transcended principle
and that's been the case because
otherwise that temptation is precedent.
Janie gone very bad idea.
Know We.
We're basically on page 10
of the essential points.
It was like being on task.
They were
really helpful and perhaps
more than you think.
So.
Awesome.
That's very cool.
Good followup to that.
Do you ever,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Nope.
No.
For me,
for me on the calls,
dangerous
legal impulsively.
I do also understand some scripts
for
smoking is probably the gate suicide.
I mean that was the whole story.
You know,
I'd say that
means that in some sense
it's careless thinking.
Everything has its risks.
Richard asked you
back to one of the rules.
You don't want people,
you don't want to just
tell you those little
get here
that I drove.
The advice that I gave
was
about that age
60,
which is perfect for me for
my
depression,
depression
and my grandfather.
I asked my daughter,
my daughter has,
she has 38
when she was 16,
she had her hip replaced
after walking around with
and she also has this impression
when that happened,
if she removed one of her illnesses,
I
which one would be
removed and she said it,
she would keep the arthritis and
so that gives you some indication.
That impression is mine
was brutally hard.
My father pointed remarks
anyways,
so I'm
feeling pretty miserable face.
What's that?
There were a bunch of things that are
wrong and then I can try to stop them and
see what happened or the crispy exterior.
I know what I'm doing wrong.
Those obvious and they'll probably make
my life worse than it has to be and
maybe there was 10 things that I remember
fight contract that I'm sort of doing
wrong and I could start not doing
those experiments and when I started,
but it was probably 20,
21.
Just what I went to graduate school.
I thought,
okay,
I'm going to see what would happen,
and I just started doing all the things
that I'm doing that are stupid that I
know where it's at.
The same time when I decided that was a
strange experience and I need to go out
a little bit in the
maximum security prison.
Just this is the patients
are very strange stuff.
Insurance
made
me think
about what I was saying and so at the
same time I decided to stop doing the
stupid things I was doing that I
knew that it was making it worse.
I was going to start saying things
that might be true and that was also
extremely shocked because I'm really
like,
I really needed it.
I was going to be
safe myself on that.
It was very uncanny because over the
four months almost a decision to revise,
like almost everything I said was the
true 95 percent of it was for show people
for books.
You deserve things that I really didn't
have just raised up shallow and deep
forms of self deception and I noticed
that if I paid attention to what I'm
saying,
I could tell when being
false because I've helped me.
He was talking to and so what I tried to
list to only say things that it make me
feel and that was really extreme
experience because to begin with almost
everything,
I said,
oh my God,
a case almost every week,
and it was a shock.
I thought,
well,
it's kind of insanity in both ways.
It's like,
is it the case that you're that false?
Which of these things that you believe
the sense of falseness and put up with
the fact that 95 percent you're doing
this all certainly you put up with
and I just started that written and
that's a good thing.
It's changed me,
almost completely
use.
It's also helped me
write
this
sentence that I
read
it
wrong and it's
wrong anyway.
I can get underneath it and try it out.
I couldn't challenge and so that's
500 page book.
There's a lot of sentences,
consequences.
Even during these times.
You're still there.
Well,
unfortunately when we
were
meeting with the Queen,
but my brother in law and sister in
what this whole experience
has been like for me,
I feel like now I'm on this jury.
At the end of yours will be the.
I think that's exactly right.
Yes sir.
I just love being honest.